on apprenait hier que mons une cour
entame une importante restructuration
dans le but d'être moins dépendante du
marché de la bière est en déclin
l'entreprise a déjà acheté un fabricant
californien de kombucha investi dans une
société de type shay est lancé une
coentreprise avec le producteur de
cannabis
exo philippe roux auteur éditeur de
bières et plaisirs et à ottawa avec nous
ce soir monsieur outremont soir bonsoir
qu'est ce qui se passe avec l'industrie
de la bière traditionnelle en ce moment
mais grosso modo c'est en rire ma
dernière année on se rend compte que
l'industrie de la bière traditionnelle
est en déclin c'est à dire que les
bières domestiques sont de moins en
moins consommé par contre là dedans il
ya des segments de bière comme les
bières de microbrasseries qui elles sont
en augmentation
donc molson s'adapte s'adapte à un
marché qui correspond plus forcément une
clientèle puisque la clientèle vieillit
mais également remplacée par une
nouvelle clientèle ouais et donc fortes
transformations métamorphose du secteur
métamorphose peut-être pas par contre
que c'en est une des premières
compagnies qui internationalement a
décidé clairement de s'identifier non
plus comme brasseur mais comme créateur
de produits alcoolisés
ça veut dire que grosso modo il s'adapte
au marché et il s'adapte aussi à des
changements de marché mais ça s'est déjà
vu strictement parlant dans les années
50 par exemple des grands brasseurs se
sont adaptés aussi aux produits en
diminuant le goût du produit pour
augmenter grosso modo les ventes des
produits puisqu'on a on a enlevé le goût
du houblon on a enlevé le goût de la
bière pour remplacer par des bières très
douce facile à boire que l'on boit plus
froide est on est on a augmenté le
marketing qui le sentiment
d'appartenance pour chaque marque est
donc là dans ce cas-ci ce qu'on est en
train de voir c'est que c'est un
changement complet regrouper une
restructuration en fait de la compagnie
pour pouvoir s'adapter aux futurs
marchés
vous l'avez dit les microbrasseries ça
va quand même assez bien donc ce sont
d'autres types de catégories de bière
qui sont en perte de marché exactement
donc les bières importés vont
relativement bien et stagnent les biens
domestiques c'est à dire les catégories
de bière blonde douce sont en baisse les
premium super premium c'est à dire les
catégories de marque de bière qui ont
une histoire
elles sont également en baisse les
microbrasseries augmente mais dans un
marché qui globalement diminue et ça et
de toute façon les grands brasseurs
depuis plusieurs années ont déjà
clairement indiqué leur intérêt à
vouloir acheter de la microbrasserie
puisqu'elle consommateurs s'intéressent
de plus en plus à la microbrasserie mais
ça crée une problématique c'est que le
microbe le consommateur s'intéresse un
segment de produits et non plus à une
marque en particulier et donc c'est
surtout ça que l'on voit changer sur le
marché c'est à dire que le consommateur
veut boire par exemple une bière
artisanale et non plus forcément une
marque de bière artisanale ça veut dire
que toutes les micro brasseries et
toutes les brasseries sont compétitives
et ce compétition entre eux est ce que
il y as pour vous clairement un effet
générationnel
tout à fait si on regarde l'historique
mans par là les jeunes voulaient des
boissons différentes aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'on veut on recherche entre autres
des boissons des jus alcoolisés sucrés à
dans les microbrasseurs répondants
faisant des alpilles et extrêmement
floral fruité avec des houblons mais qui
reste quand même su créer des grands
brasseurs répondent parfois avec des
halles comme halte est actuellement on
voit un changement qui s'en vient
également pas forcément sur d'alcool
puisque depuis l'ouverture du marché du
cannabis
on va pouvoir également avoir des
boissons qui vont être à base de
cannabis ne pourra pas contenir d'alcool
par exemple et ça c'est un nouveau
marché molson s'y prépare mais ce sont
pas les seuls
je suis persuadé même que labatt que le
grand concurrent de molson est en train
également de regarder quelque chose de
son côté pour la simple et bonne raison
que c'est un marché qui est très
prometteur pour l'ensemble des grandes
brasseries qui ne sont même plus devenu
qu'ils ne deviennent même plus des
grands brasseurs puisque le soleil des
grands producteurs de boissons les
grands producteurs de boissons et des
d'enfants des entreprises qui ont une
forme d' expertise une expertise dans le
goût dans la découverte dans le loisir
en quelque sorte parce que je voyais
aussi des idées du vrai en canette du
café alcoolisé il ya toutes sortes de
choses qu'on peut faire mais ils ont
surtout une expertise dans la vente et
et ccc grosso modo sac que molson a
présenté hier c'est à dire ils vont
retirer une partie des tâches
administratives venant de certains
employés pour des secteurs qui sont
moins porteur pour les rediriger vers
d'autres secteurs et molson est partout
donc ça veut dire qu'ils sont capables
de vendre ils sont capables de district
lui et est le nerf de la guerre
actuellement c'est la position de la
boisson sur les tablettes chez les
détaillants et ça effectivement la
tablette n'est pas extensible
donc il va falloir avoir une force de
vente qui va être capable d'être
multidisciplinaire avec différents
produits et nous le sommes nous a tout
simplement informé que c'est vers ça qui
s'en allait tout simple et qu'est ce que
ça veut dire pour l'avenir des
microbrasseries ou des nouveaux
producteurs des nouvelles brasseries qui
arrivent sur le marché que ces
changements dans le marché actuellement
mais les microbrasseries continue de
développer une expansion depuis à peu
près cinq ans on a une moyenne
d'augmentation de microbrasseurs au
québec de 15 18% donc ça veut dire que
on est rendu à peu près aux alentours de
230 permis ça veut dire aussi que les
microbrasseurs doivent concurrencer non
plus forcément avec des bières mais
également avec d'autres produits et donc
offrir une expérience est ce qu'on se
rend compte c'est que la nouvelle
génération de consommateurs
le serbe ne veut pas forcément de
l'alcool mais veut vivre une expérience
alors soit avec avec du thé a chez soi
avec du cbd mais ce n'est plus forcément
l'alcool qui a la primauté au niveau 2
de l'ivresse entre limoux et donc là le
les bonnes vieilles bière qu'on a connus
la lemos une cause les mots sonnent
canadienne les labat et cetera sont en
pleine transformation
oui d'ailleurs molson nous a déjà
démontré qu'ils sont ils sont assez
proactif sur la création de d'anciennes
marque la marque o'keefe qui vient de
rentrer en magasin historiquement
parlant là laurentides la batte avec la
labatt 50 également donc il ya un
sentiment d'appartenance de patriotisme
de côté vintage ainsi que ce que
j'allais dire un petit côté vintage
exactement et dont il joue là dessus
pour aller rechercher une clientèle qui
s'y intéressent mais la nouvelle
clientèle consomme différemment il faut
s'adapter et à molson a tout simplement
indiqué que cela peut plus en plus de
5500 revient avec une nouvelle usine à
longueuil
donc ils vont ils vont ils vont pouvoir
étant encore plus concurrentiel sur un
marché très dynamique en tout cas
exactement oui monsieur motors merci je
vous en prie merci beaucoup